if they let toby mcguire have one line
in the trailer like just a real moment
you know that music fades down faded yes
with great power
comes great responsibility that would be
so cool billion dollars right there
and then you hear willing to fall off
the screen say godspeed spider-man
though
yeah
and that totally impales toby mcguire
into the actual trailer
what's going on reject nation greg and
john here all right listen listen i know
for those who watch the uh reaction we
did to a spiderman no way home thinking
yesterday there was a comment saying
like we're not only gonna be putting out
spiderman vids this week and i wasn't
expecting us to do one so soon again the
very next day but then this dropped from
our buddy warren and i was like
we gotta check this out we we just gotta
check it out and then on twitter he put
out this tweet right here that says hey
spiderman no way home fans you're gonna
want to watch my event today and watch
till the end the last line gave me
goosebumps we're doing this let's see
what's in store a lot he's been right
about so far so yeah curious to hear
what's in here
[Music]
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and of
course spider-man no way home if you
thought that the hype would calm down
after the first trailer came out no that
does not seem to be the case this
trailer pretty much only made the hype
get even bigger showing us a glimpse of
the spider-verse that is to come by
showing us alfred molina's doc ock
showing us a pumpkin bomb and other
parts of the sinister six as well now we
did not see the other two spider-man
andrew garfield and toby mcguire but
have no fear they will be in the movie
whether or not they'll show them in the
next trailer or the one after that or
simply save them for the movie who knows
but in the meantime i think i have
something that could hold people over
for just a little bit we have some of
their lines that they're going to be
saying in spider-man nowhere speaking to
each other speaking to tom holland
spider-man speaking to the villains i
hope you acted out reliable source in
fact this source gave us a description
of what the teaser trailer was going to
show weeks before it even came out and
when it came out it was pretty much
exactly like this person said paul from
heavy spoilers
some of these lines like this line that
comes from toby speaking to tom and
andrew he says we can beat them together
obviously this is about them fighting
the sinister six it's so simple
so the line i want to start with even
though i've already given you one is one
that i find particularly pretty funny
and i've seen several memes about this
line already and it is is this stuff
coming out of you this is from
who actually produces the webs he
doesn't actually have web shooters and
this is something that i've actually
always personally liked about toby
maguire spider-man i like the organic
webbing quite a bit and this was a
conversation that was coming up during
our live stream this week since the idea
of toby popping up in here came to the
conversation i've always wanted to see
the banter back and forth of like their
reaction to the webbing coming out of
toby making like jokes about it as well
so yeah having that line
you know there's going to be something
even if this line is not 100 what it is
you know there's going to be something
this is the one piece of marvel humor i
have been looking forward to now i'm not
going in any particular order of the
movie just simply stating some of the
lines that are listed here and another
one is from william defoe
spider-man where he says the wizard said
he'd get us back to where we came from
but we can't go back now obviously this
is the green goblin talking to tom
holland spider-man and he's saying they
can't go back because they were taken
right from where they died so if they
get sent back to their own universe
they'll get sent back to right before
they died and it'll lead to them dying
so obviously they don't want to go back
and speaking of them dying here's a line
from electro to andrew garfield
spider-man well well if it isn't my
murderer because we all know what
happened at the end of the amazing
spider-man 2. wait that applies a
different thing though doesn't it a bit
the theory is that they all come out of
you know their universe right before
they die so i mean are they all treating
spider-man or their spider-man like yeah
yeah no you are my murderer
applying a resurrection seconds longer
you would have killed me or yeah or is
it
yeah yeah yeah resurrection would be
kind of cool here's an interesting one
this is willem dafoe's green goblin to
tom holland spider-man and he says we
are who we choose to be now choose and
this kind of sounds like the green
goblin is manipulating tom
killed us do you want to be a killer you
don't have to be the other spiderman
were but you don't have to be you can
set us free pretty much right now we
know that doctor strange is going to
somehow keep all of these villains
locked up you can trust me i'm a goblin
and it sounds like it somehow might be
due to the manipulation of the green
goblin he also posted this weeks before
the trailer came out and here's a line
that we saw in the trailer you've never
done anything on this magnitude strange
don't cast that spell it's too dangerous
wong to doctor strange we saw this and
just for reference this was literally
posted like 50 days ago so way before
the treatment
[Music]
okay here's what i'm thinking
all right just uh throw a little bit of
doubt here this trailer has been in
development for such a long time now
that leaked trailer that came out maybe
they saw an earlier version of that and
then so what they did was they took
lines from the leak and then also threw
in some other own so that way they can
use that to support
their leaks yeah you know maybe that's
just a big maybe you know i'm just i'm
just saying there's there's ways to add
points to your argument here by pulling
some actual quotes from a real leak
here's another electro to andrew
garfield line i'm gonna kill the light
so everyone in this city is gonna know
how it feels to live in my world a world
without power wow a world without mercy
a world without spider-man he seems like
he could be just a tiny bit bitter and
the cool thing is that it does not very
dark it kind of seems like some of the
lines are going to come from their
original movies or at least derived from
them for example here's a line from
willem the foe's green goblin to tom
holland spider-man the itsy bitsy spider
climbed up the water spout down came the
goblin and took the spider out sounds a
little familiar huh and i can't wait
until he actually says this to our
spiderman tom holland spiderman here's
another one
again proving this is true because this
was 50 days ago doctor strange to tom
holland we tampered with the stability
of space-time another one that was
proven true after mysterio revealed my
identity my entire life got screwed up i
was wondering if maybe you can go back
in time and make it so that he never did
and here are four lines that i really
really love and i think a lot of people
if you are big big spider-man fans which
i know a lot of us are are probably
going to get pretty teary-eyed at some
point in time in this movie whether it's
an emotional scene or it's just is it
about uncle ben all three spider-man
together whether they're happy tears
emotional tears i think they're coming
this is one from the very first
spider-man that hits me right in the
nostalgia toby to willem dafoe i have a
father his name was ben parker in which
it seems like willem dafoe says god
speed spider-man but he says this not to
toby maguire but he says it to tom
holland then this is from toby to tom
your ben how did he die and you
automatically know this is going to be a
super emotional scene i would love it if
tom's like who oh yeah sorry for my
suitcase
oh my uncle
from my suitcase yeah guys can you tell
me about this ben guys scene i never
knew
my man's just been single
no i'm liking that and the last line
that is listed here says you're not
alone you have us toby and andrew to tom
now if you can just visualize these
scenes visualize toby mcguire and andrew
garfield and tom holland all talking to
each other you can get a tiny little
glimpse of just how epic this film is
going to be now of course i want to end
it with the biggest and best line that
we could possibly ever get in this
spider-man no way home it's pizza time i
did not hear these words toby mcguire to
tom holland don't ever forget these
words with great power comes great
responsibility then andrew looks over
he's like that's so much catchier than
what my benz
comes from toby mcguire to tom holland
gives me chips yeah and i really really
really hope that we see it in the movie
again this was all posted about 50 days
ago way before the trailer came out and
this person also posted a description of
the trailer which ended up being true
and some of these lines in here we heard
in the trailer so we have no reason not
to believe that these aren't actual
lines actual dialogue that is going to
be in spider-man no way home it's funny
because when he did say that on twitter
like the last line and that is that that
was so there for some reason my mind
wasn't even thinking about that would be
a cheering moment in the theater i think
if it does say thousands the spider-man
quote oh yeah and i'm conflicted here
because i'm like it would be cool if
they say that for the movie but if they
let toby maguire have one line in the
trailer like just a real moment you know
that music fades down faded yes with
great power
comes great responsibility that would be
so cool billion dollars right there
and then you hear willing to fall off
the screen and say godspeed spider-man
though
and that totally impales toby mcguire
into the actual trailer
so let me know what you think about
these in the comments down below and if
you want to stay up to date on
everything in the mcu and spiderman be
sure to subscribe
begs for food and knock stuff down
on instagram and twitter i do work thank
you all so much for watching woof woof
meow meow meow is that right isn't that
right guitar cat
okay guys well yeah that was awesome
that was awesome i did love that that
did give me some chills i am hyped what
do you want them to say i hope they say
it's pizza time oh yeah okay someone fix
the damn door
all i want are toby lines i hope someone
says your daddy or uncle he believed in
a principle an ideal really
you know it's got a responsibility to
keep around that power our love for toby
to say
with a great power comes great
responsibility and andrew goes that's a
lot more efficient than what my uncle
said
quebec could have learned a lot from
your uncle then
all right guys thanks for being here
we'll catch you guys soon